on
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir pour ce
deuxième week-end du mois le temps sera
agréable toujours vos pas trop chaud des
détails à la fin de ce journal
une bonne nouvelle pour tous ceux ils
sont très nombreux qui devait finir de
payer leurs impôts le 15 ou en effet
comme c'est un jour férié qu'il ya
ensuite un pont le délai prolongé vous
avez jusqu'au mardi 19 minuit pour finir
de régler vos impôts sur le revenu sur
les sociétés
la taxe professionnelle et les autres
impôts locaux mais attention au delà de
mardi minuit les bontés d'administration
s'arrête et vous auriez à payer 10%
poursuivant sa route pc ravages de ces
clones allen a largement dépassé des
caraïbes où il a fait au moins 87 morts
et d'ici deux à trois heures aux
environs de minuit heure de paris il
devrait toucher les côtes sud du texas
les vents ont très légèrement faibli
mais il pousse encore des pointes à 260
km à l'heure les gens se calfeutre font
des provisions attendent
et surtout ils ont peur êtes vous prêt
pour allen 17 ans cadre à supermarché
rasier par les ménagères le texas fait
des provisions en prévision de l'ouragan
le courant sera coupé en achètent des
bougies les robinets se tariront on
s'arrache le minéral pour lutter contre
les vents ont clos départ cyclone
planches de bois qui devrait résister
aux rafales ou ne résisteront pas ceux
qui le peuvent gagner l'intérieur des
terres pour éviter la marée d'ouragan
allen le voile a vu deux satellites
énorme virulent - pourtant cuillère au
contact des terres et d'eau plus froids
de cyclone a baissé d'intensité mais il
a de beaux restes
les heures d'haleine son compte et celle
de ses victimes aussi les premières
spirale de nuages ont atteint la côte un
encas avant le paroxysme
le plus dur ce sera cette nuit dans le
noir
demain alain sera mort et combien avec
lui demain on relèvera les maisons les
pylônes électriques on nettoiera les
rues bombardée par les vents et les
vagues
demain s'en sera fini de la sécheresse
qui sévit sur le sud des états unis
depuis plusieurs semaines demain on
attendra le prochain ouragan car depuis
110 ans les usa subissent au moins un
cyclone chaque année seule exception
1890 on a l'habitude dit s'il est en
fait mais on n'oubliera pas allen qui
vous salue bien
belfast a connu l'année dernière sa plus
grave explosion de violences depuis des
années six morts et quatre blessés
grièvement atteints en fait et depuis
longtemps des événements sanglants se
produisent dans la capitale de l'irlande
du nord principalement au mois d'août
par scoop marque l'anniversaire d'un
décret promulgué il ya neuf ans par les
autorités britanniques un texte qui
autorise l'incarcération sans procès
dans les affaires de terrorisme
un commentaire d'edward une nuit d'
incendies d'émeutes et le réveil ce
matin d'une capitale qui une fois de
plus compte ses morts et ses blessés
belfast en guerre depuis maintenant onze
ans avec chaque année ce mois tragique
du mois d'août
devenu presque habituelle et cette nuit
encore les militaires britanniques
auront relevé six victimes dont une
jeune fille de 14 ans avec la crainte de
voir se déclencher demain des événements
encore plus tragique
les catholiques ayant annoncé pour ce
dimanche une manifestation générale dans
bellechasse qui sera suivi par un
rassemblement des loyalistes
c'est à dire des protestants
onze années d'un conflit aujourd'hui
presque oublié du monde entier mais où
il faut pratiquement à chaque week end
revoir un bilan qui dépasse déjà les
deux mille morts
iran le parlement à proposer monsieur
ali rajaï pour le poste de premier
ministre le président de la république
bani sadr après d'assez longues
hésitations à entériner ce choix
mais la désignation officielle reste à
faire monsieur rajaï à 47 ans il fut
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
le gouvernement de monsieur lazhar gants
l'homme qui avait succédé vous le
rappeler à chapour bakhtiar monsieur
radja et connu pour ses opinions
intégristes conte ses prises de position
intransigeante de militants islamiques
et pour son anticommunisme la fp câble
de moscou que les relations entre l'iran
et l'urss sont proches du point de
rupture
teheran menace de rappeler son
ambassadeur et le kremlin se plaint de
ce qu'il appelle les attaques haineuses
de l'iran où certains promettent
soviétique le sort des américains une
dépêche de dernière heure l'imam comme
eni a qualifié l'urss de grandes
puissances satanique à paris monsieur
chapour bakhtiar a créé un mouvement de
résistance nationale iranienne où ils
espèrent être rejoints par tous se dit
il qui désirent sauver leur pays de
l'emprise du régime actuel arrivé à
paris de monsieur bah ça râle chaque
amer de naplouse en cisjordanie et qui
avait dû être amputé des deux jambes à
la suite d'un attentat commis le 2 juin
monsieur le chat car a été invité par
les autorités françaises afin de suivre
un traitement médical qu'il continuera
ensuite en grande bretagne il a exprimé
sa profonde reconnaissance pour une
habitation dont il est l'objet et par
ailleurs monsieur yasser arafat a remis
à l'ambassadeur de france à beyrouth un
message de vifs remerciements aux
autorités françaises pour l'hospitalité
accordée aux mères de naplouse
en ces circonstances jean pierre billon
diète et à orly à l'arrivée un peu agité
de monsieur al chacun
monsieur le shaq a été accueilli à paris
par le délégué de l'ol paix dans notre
pays monsieur ibrahim sousse et de
nombreux membres du corps diplomatique
arabe
le maire de naplouse est une
personnalité influente qui avaient été
incarcérés au début d'année par l est
l'hyper israélien des territoires
occupés il avait alors entrepris une
grève de la faim avant d'être libérés
sur ordre de la cour suprême d'israël
à son arrivée à orly monsieur xhaka a
indiqué quel rôle d'après lui pouvait
jouer l'europe dans le conflit du
moyen-orient alors que le chef du
gouvernement luxembourgeois
monsieur gaston thorn est en train
d'achever une tournée remarquée des
capitales arabes dollar et ma fille
chèques n'ont pas marqué dans les
rapports moral est sans aucun doute le
représentant politique majeur sur la
scène internationale et la position de
leur prend ce moment précis et
extrêmement important et il fallait car
je pense que cette période que nous
traversons n'est pas simplement utile et
bénéfique pour la cause palestinienne
mais pour le rétablissement de la prison
de montres et de là vient le
le rôle important de l'europe dans les
relations internationales
le conflit de la pêche ne s'arrange pas
à boulogne-sur-mer cercle et marins ont
décidé dans l'espace du week end
ailleurs de lever leur barrage aux
sorties du port et de les remplacer par
des actions de commandos afin d'empêcher
des importations et par ailleurs les
syndicats cgt cfdt des marins pêcheurs
ont dénoncé aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
appellent le diktat des armes à terre
pour les syndicalistes à convention
collective et violées les chalutiers en
tout cas sont à quai les marins pêcheurs
les dockers poissonnier les salariés de
la marie conserve sa saison risque ainsi
de se trouver dès le début de la semaine
son travail est fait quant à son tour
est touchée par la grève
le point à boulogne par fr3 l'île au
cours d'une conférence de presse tenue
ce matin à boulogne les syndicats cgt
cfdt des marins pêcheurs ont à nouveau
insisté sur le fait qu'il n'était pas en
grève et qu'il se considérait comme le
cas où tu es par les armateurs qui ne
veulent plus renvoyer les bateaux en mer
avec les équipages prévues par
l'actuelle convention collective
ils ont annoncé qu'ils porteraient
plainte lundi à ce sujet ils ont annoncé
par ailleurs qu'il vont demander
audience au ministre de tutelle de la
pêche monsieur le tél
et ils ont appelé toute la population
boulonnaise commerçants compris à
participer à la manifestation
interprofessionnelle prévue mercredi
soir sur le port même la situation est
restée stationnaire malgré la levée
partielle des barrages établis d'hier
seuls quelques mareyeurs ont racheté un
peu de poisson frais aux artisans et
emploi
monsieur hamelin député udf de la vienne
demandent au ministre de la défense
d'assouplir la réglementation en vigueur
pour les jeunes créateurs d'entreprises
qui sont appelés à effectuer leur
service national
le pape qui poursuit ses vacances à
castel gandolfo s'est adressée
aujourd'hui à une centaine d'anciens
drogués en leur disant en substance
c'est une erreur de considérer certaines
drogues comme douce
le pape est opposée à un projet de loi
italien visant à libéraliser
d'utilisation de ces drogues selon le
souverain pontife l'expérience
douloureuse de plusieurs pays confirme
qu'une législation permissive dans ce
domaine ne sert ni à prévenir ni
aguerris à râler ou d'une grève qui n'en
finit pas celle des acteurs de
complément et des figurants ce qui
retarde la production de nombreux
feuilletons de télévision sans parler
des films un reportage du représentant
permanent d'antenne 2 en californie
claude gaits pratiquement plus à mètres
de pellicule le sort des studios de los
angeles qui habituellement produisent
plus d'un film par jour sans compter les
feuilletons dont on tourne l'épisode par
semaine depuis le 21 juillet on a été
les projecteurs les 70000 acteurs et
musiciens du cinéma et de la télévision
sont en grève soixante dix mille en se
regardant défiler avec les autres
comédiens attendri m'a dit tout de même
c'est là qu'on se rend compte qu'on est
à hollywood et l'attendrissement ne dure
pas trente mille d'entre eux n'ont
effectivement pas souvent l'occasion de
se rendre compte qu'ils vivent dans la
capitale du cinéma
ils sont sans emploi et jouer ce jour
leurs premiers rôles de l'année celui
naturel de chômeurs si on tourne
toujours beaucoup à los angeles les
figurants diminué en même temps que les
budgets sapin ou gagnent moins de 4000
francs dans le mois 9 millions de
dollars pour deux boxeurs qui sont
passés à la télévision 9 millions en une
nuit et nous mourons de faim pas un
penny à l'origine de la bataille bien
sûr l'argent mais on se bat aujourd'hui
sur un terrain inconnu celui ouvert par
le progrès de la communication et des
médias
depuis toujours les acteurs reçoivent
des royalties ou des cachets chaque fois
qu'un film auquel ils ont participé et
diffusés ou rediffusés sur une chaîne de
télévision privée mais de nouvelles
formes de diffusion sont apparus et
conquiert le marché
la vidéocassette le vidéo disent que les
télévision par câble qui compte un
abonnement propos sur le petit écran des
films non entrecoupée de publicité
aucun contrat aucune loi ne régit ces
nouveaux marchés et les comédiens ne
reçoivent pas de compensation c'est pour
obtenir une part du pactole qui leur
échappe et avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
quand le marché sera plus développé que
les acteurs se sont mis en grève le
problème toutefois et qu'on ne verra
aucune star à cette manifestation
pas de robert redford ou de jane fonda
ni d'al pacino de charlton heston cela
gagne plusieurs million par film n'ont
pas besoin pour vivre des retombées
secondaire du marché de la vidéo
cassettes et cette manifestation en fait
malgré son côté bon enfant les sourires
et les retrouvailles des figurants qui
ne s'étaient pas vues sur un plateau
depuis deux ans cette manifestation
était bien triste
les petits pourtant gagneront leur grève
paralyse le monde du cinéma qui perd une
fortune chaque jour
les studios sont fermés les tournages
sont repoussés et les grandes chaînes de
télévision les networks ebe à essevee si
nbc
si la grève se poursuit devront à la
rentrée rediffusé d'anciens feuilletons
les plus grandes stars ont besoin d'être
entouré il faut toujours un clown et les
clowns se sont fâchés une histoire
presque morale maintenant presque à
mont-saint-martin près de longwy l'école
communale avait été visité par de jeunes
vandales il avait cassé le mobilier
vider les armoires barbouillé les murs
de peinture et tué des tourterelles de
très jeunes vandales
ils sont âgés de 5 à 7 la mairie a pris
un accord avec les parents ils aideront
leurs enfants à réparer des dégâts et la
commune ne poursuivra pas la faire si
les parents de chacun des trois enfants
travaille 60 heures pour la municipalité
ils devront par exemple placer des bancs
et des boîtes à ordures dans les rues de
la petite cité c'est une manière comme
une autre de régler de semblable
incident à voile à 18 heures on a donné
le départ de la course en solitaire du
figaro épreuve créée il ya une dizaine
d'années par l'horreur première étape
perros guirec côtes sud de l'irlande
ensuite retour en france
puis ce sera l'espagne 51 concurrents
dont trois jeunes femmes et un starter
véritablement du métier tabarly lui même
considère cette course comme étant une
des plus dures au monde
mais aussi une des plus belles un
parcours non 2190 milles nautiques en
quatre étapes
les concurrents sont unanimes le plus
dur sera le manque de sommeil
la hantise de s'endormir et de ne
pouvoir se réveiller si le vent change
et ainsi de perdre de précieuses heures
ils étaient 12 en 1970 à prendre le
départ pour la course de 1980 les
organisateurs ont dû créer une épreuve
de sélection afin de limiter le nombre
de participants avec des noms tels que
gainey eliès malinowski vers l'italie
burchill est normal que cette course
puisse intéresser les futurs mouvements
de masse de l'esprit car altenheim le
grand prix d'allemagne de formule 1
celui là même que patrick de payer
préparer la semaine dernière lors de son
accident il a trouvé la mort ce sont les
français jabouille aire nou après la
première séance officielle des essais
qui avait réalisé le meilleur temps
après la dernière séance c'est
l'australien adam jones qui a réalisé le
temps de meilleurs et qui partira donc
en tête devant les deux français
l'australien angels risque demain de
faire ce que l'on appelle à cech le coup
de chapeau pour cela il faut remporter
trois victoires de suite
déjà vainqueur au castellet du grand
prix de france et à brands hatch en
angleterre
il partira en tant que favori demain en
rock'n'roll après les meilleurs temps
des deux renault turbo réalisé lors de
la première séance d'essais
il a coiffé de cinq centièmes de seconde
jean pierre jabouille et partira donc en
première position sur la grille de
départ
ce grand prix sera disputée sur une
distance de plus de 300 km et le grand
duel entre les williams et renault les
ligier et la brabham du brésilien nelson
piquet tu devrait enthousiasmer les cent
vingt mille spectateurs qui sont
attendus
rené arnoux troisième au classement du
championnat du monde a retrouvé le
sourire
il n'est qu'à 14 points du leader et
avec les nouveaux pneus michelin et sa
renault turbo qui sera avantagé sur les
longues lignes droites du circuit
il espère bien ajouter une troisième
victoire à son palmarès de la saison
les vacances c'est souvent l'art de ne
rien faire mais il y en a qui profitent
de leurs vacances pour travailler louis
doucet rencontre dans le dauphiné des
gens qui dédaignaient la bronzette et
qui préférait flirté avec la science en
fait la science a ses amateurs qu'elle
est vraie ce qu'un pic ne renie pas ce
reportage de plonger au fond de l'eau
mais il nous fait remonter jusqu'à la
prise pour ce gros baigneurs rouge qui
se promènent au fond du lac de paladru à
charavines dans le dauphiné cherche des
traces d'un village préhistorique
englouti il ya quelque chose comme cinq
mille ans venus d'un peu partout ils
sont plusieurs amateurs à passer leurs
vacances ainsi et depuis quatre étés que
cela dure il continue sous contrôle
scientifique bien entendu à remonter pas
mal de choses significatives d'une
époque où les gens quoi que l'on en
pense n'était par des sauvages vêtus de
peaux de bêtes
c'est la céramique aussi
tu l'as bien relevé plein avec la
céramique à côté pointé en place à se
dessiner mais vous trouvez souvent des
objets de cette qualité par aux fouilles
de cette qualité dans ce cas est
exceptionnel mais en a trouvé de
nombreuses cuillère légèrement plus
petite
quelquefois un peu fracturée c'est un
objet mais temps assez court ans était
connu haïti compte vous savez pour un
profane on peut avoir l'impression que
ça pourrit dans l'eau justement l'eau
concert à l'abri de l'oxygène l'abri de
la lumière quand servent les objets de
bois facilement en dizaines de
millénaires
norauto midas que les plongeurs en
sortie de l'eau oui et vous trouver
parfois des choses doivent donc oui on
trouve bien sert à lui des silex deal
bois enfin les eaux qu'est ce que vous
faites honte à lui jette la wii ou ça et
angers vous ne voulez pas payer 1 c'est
une façon pour ces vacances oui ça vous
alain millet vol oui si nous sommes
revenus
oui mais tout compte fait vous trouvé
beaucoup de matériel dans ces fouilles
oui on trouve beaucoup de matériel mais
on trouve par exemple parler les vases
remonter comme ça ils ont été remontés
par la suite dans les retrouverons ce
salon est sûr c'est un gros morceau il y
en a beaucoup plus petit et des choses
étonnantes comme qu'est ce que c'est que
ça ah ça c'est un ange 2h alors je vais
vous remontez la hache avec un éclat qui
a sauté l'un alan éclats de bois qui a
sauté et voilà la hache oui dans se
servait nous on aux ancêtres il ya 5000
ans et puis jouer ce ci est un arc
ah ça c'est une pièce exceptionnelle qui
a été découverte cette année vous la
voyez bien sûr dans un tube en plastique
parce qu'elle ne peut pas prendre l'air
il faut qu'elle soit absolument
conserver dans l'ue minimes et vous
prenez toutes les précautions pour lui
conserver leur insu et puis on trouve
des objets comme comme ceux ci qui
ressemble un peu à une feinte de 4,1
d'ailleurs et c'est un peigne mais c'est
pas un peigne pour se baigner c'est un
peigne pour faire du tissage et puis
vous avez surtout ses hommes se sent d
poignard en silex qui ont conservé leur
manche en bois
on retrouve aussi des poignets en silex
qui malheureusement ont perdu leurs
manches et ceux ci qu'est ce que celle
il est rigoureusement semblable au
panier que l'on peut faire actuellement
mais qui étaient ces gens que vous
poursuivez jusqu'au fond des eaux
c'était des agriculteurs dit à 5000 ans
qui ont peuplé le dauphiné et dont on
suit par les restes végétaux par les
petits outils de moi on dont on suit la
vie quotidienne et c'est ça qui est
important
c'était des gens qui avaient des
civilisations artisanale très évolués
qui savait se servir des outils de silex
qui savait taille et le bois
qui savait faire très bien la céramique
qui mangeait bien des végétaux qui
cultivait le blé l'orge le lin pour les
vêtements mais vous pouvez aller très
loin dans la recherche du quotidien avec
vos techniques modernes les techniques
modernes sont quelquefois ahurissante
prenez par exemple un outil comme cet
outils de silex un de ses outils
semblables ont été analysés et il porte
des petites dents au microscope
électronique à balayage on s'aperçoit
que le silex a littéralement fondu à
l'endroit où ils travaillent et par une
élévation ponctuelle de température et
les cellules les fragments de particules
arraché au moment du travail de l'otite
sont fixés à l'intérieur jusqu'à christ
est littéralement incrustée et alors
cinq mille ans après on retrouve des
cellules végétales des cellules animales
qui permettent de dire par exemple des
outils de ce type ont coupé de la viande
au dessus de l'osce vous ne pouvez tout
de même par constituer le menu du jour
non enfin savoir qui sera coupé de la
viande cette importante question
subsidiaire quel seront les conclusions
des archéologues qui fouleront la même
plage dans cette mise en
nous sommes désolés tout à l'heure nous
avons passé cette photographie de
monsieur pierre abelin décédé the pierre
abelin ancien ministre alors que je
parlais de son fils monsieur jean pierre
abelin député udf de la vienne qui je
vous le rappelle a demandé au ministre
de la défense d'assouplir la
réglementation en vigueur pour les
jeunes créateurs d'entreprises qui sont
appelés à effectuer leur service
national
cette confusion est regrettable et je
demande à la famille de bien vouloir ne
pas nous en tenir rigueur course à
partir de demain il y aura chaque
dimanche du mois d'août deux réunions et
pmu des courses au trot en région
parisienne soit par un gain soit de
vincennes et une réunion au galop à
deauville le tiercé du dimanche aura
toujours lieu à douille cependant demain
il s'agira d'un handicap sur 2000 mètres
près de la municipalité 18 partants et
voici les préférés de pierre et willy
pas facile ce tiercé demain 2000 mètres
piste e ronde c'est le profil du
parcours que les 18 concurrents du
tiercé devront entre ac demain dans prix
de la municipalité de deauville cela
promet du spectacle car les chevaux qui
auront tiré le mauvais numéro à la corde
voudront s'en rapprocher pour avoir une
chance de disputer l'arrivée
tout cela en galopant à toute allure mes
chevaux possédant une bonne pointe de
vitesse seront avantagés nous avons
essayé de découvrir tout d'abord dany
ricky porte 50 kilos dans cette course
handicap de deauville est un peu
particulière ce qu'il convient à venir
votre cheval et et j'espère qu'ils
veuillent convenir le danger dans sur
son champ de courses à deauville c'est
le nom de partants qui est là baudis de
et moi j'ai tiré le numéro 17 à la corde
il va y avoir beaucoup d'impondérables
j'ai un peu un peu inquiet à cause de ce
numéro
et sinon sinon je perdais toi mieux il
faut que cette opa pied une première
chance et il devrait participer à
l'arrivée s'il n'y avait pas eu ce
numéro qui lui sera tout de même très
défavorable il portera à cinq ans
tranquille ou d'une autre à 53 kg il
sera monté par la loco qui le connaît
très bien
quittons jockey en forme qui n'ajoute
est en grande forme j'espère qu'il sera
en tirent le meilleur parti
la 24 ans vous êtes l'un de nos plus
jeunes entraîneurs mais vous ne craignez
pas de prendre des risques parce que
vous avez engagé l'aventurier dans le
tiercé et moi je pense que le loup est
un peu difficile pour lui non non non je
pense pas tu as déjà prouvé dans ces
eaux là et il est déjà sixième temps sur
ses rivaux discrétion à gagner dans le
show propre à s'asseoir au risque penser
qu'il est une très bonne chose a une
petite chance
d'abord parce qu'il est bien placé au
poids et est ensuite il est très très
bien il le chante cousineau ville du
coup vient ça doit d'avoir peut-être
malinois petit peu courte
puis la mauvais numéro à la cour et le
14 à l'extérieur cela n'avantage pas sur
2000 m vous y croyez vraiment en tête de
la sélection je plaçais tout d'abord
chaque dom bien qu'ils portent 60 kg le
poids le plus élevé de la course est un
cheval de classe diego a été préparé
tout spécialement envie de cette épreuve
danny lee a lui aussi visé ce tiercé
skin drifter a déjà gagné cette course
l'année dernière interdit à la
réputation d'être cabochard mais s'il
est décidé il peut même gagner cette
épreuve action est arrivé à son meilleur
niveau de préparation mogami à très
mauvais caractère mais aussi d'hommes en
hommage car c'est un cheval de classe
l'aventurier 45 kg le plus petit poids
de la course terminera la sélection et
ses shows porteront les numéros 1 8 9 15
6 16 10 et 18 le château de vincennes
est fermée au public depuis la vente
hier jusqu'à demain soir inclus
c'est que l'on tourne devant son donjon
et danser phocéen film d'après le
célèbre roman de charles dickens de
tales of two cities de titre provisoire
du film est d'ailleurs la traduction du
titre du livre l'histoire de deux villes
l'action se déroule lors de la
révolution française et certaines
parties du château de vincennes peuvent
fort bien figurer la bastille qui fut
vous le savez complètement détruite
aussitôt après le 14 juillet 10 189 un
reportage sur le tournage du film par
monique atlan
la tour de londres résistant à tous les
assauts la bastille détruites pour le
meilleur et pour le pire c'est le
château de vincennes que le metteur en
scène britannique et jean godard a
choisi d'investir pour le tournage d'une
superproduction des trois heures sur
fond de révolution française
plusieurs millions de dollars pour une
prise de la bastille en plan séquence
perpétrés par près de 450 figure way ses
environs
tableau messieurs qui descendait la
gauche est celle là sans vous donner la
gauche au dessin j'ai inventé ici et
vous détailler sur les branches soit pas
gêné mais la gauche est là dont les
montres ici chaque sans-culottes
figurants professionnels acteurs au
chômage ont étudiants en mal d'argent en
poche reçoit en moyenne 200 francs par
jour pour avoir les privilèges
après des heures et des heures
d'attentes de jouer les révolutionnaires
à répétition avec il faut le dire plus
ou moins de conviction pour les besoins
de la production dans le calme là bas
s'il vous plaît monsieur s'il vous plaît
vous avez été très gentillet rosés tire
plus nombreux assoyez chouette
aujourd'hui voter oui mais toi tu es
gentil tu comprends tout
on sait que demain un raccord parce que
c'est la suite
d'une ronde que l'on a fait suit après
les high risk kraft qui vont se combiner
et là on ne sait jamais à l'avancé vous
ne connaissez pas le scénario en fait
non et que quand on a les rôles
en quoi consiste votre rôle sur le
guignol s'agitant beaucoup dans
l'ailleurs méchant puis souvent on fait
les mouvements poule quoi on prend la
bastille
fait deux jours qu'on prend la bastille
bonjour la guéguerre ses parents
c'est amusant c'est quoi
c'est un élément de cartons du décor
mais matelas est garanti pour cette
révolution tout confort destiné en
priorité aux téléspectateurs américains
de la nbc
le tournage se termine dimanche soir et
le chapeau vincennes accueillera à
nouveau le public
ensuite la météo et bien demain le temps
sera souvent ensoleillé sur la plupart
des régions après dissipation des brumes
matinales dans le sud ouest en
particulier
toutefois près des côtes de la manche de
la bretagne au pas-de-calais de les
nuages seront plus abondants malgré
quelques éclaircies
vent faible à modéré est températures
stationnaires vers 23h30 vous avez
rendez vous avec pierre-alain qui vous
donnera les dernières informations de la
journée et demain nous nous retrouverons
si vous voulez bien des antennes de
mythe
bonne soirée merci